the Golden Globes are last night and the
stars were out in force for Hollywood's
fifth or sixth biggest platform two-four
actors to make political statements
instead of just accepting their awards
to recap to recap Casey Affleck appeared
to have been bitten by a radioactive
rabbi and everyone loved lala land the
feel-good musical set in LA that proves
that anyone can make it as long as you
got a song in your heart a dance on your
step and your two of the most attractive
people on the planet now in case you
didn't know hidden figures and fences
are two entirely different movies
featuring african-american leads that
both received multiple nominations but
don't tell that to red carpet reporter
Jenna Bush Hager
[Music]
I mean forever he's not even angry you
can just hear him deflate you know this
the only thing this was missing was the
Curb Your Enthusiasm music sting but
[Music]
[Applause]
music makes everything a better
including corn now I know this looks bad
but let's give her the benefit of the
doubt you know hidden fences ISM maybe
it's a real movie somewhere maybe that
is a real movie somewhere comedians give
us the tagline for hidden fences fan
will Stevie Wonder be able to give his
lawnmower business off the ground and
avoid all the obstacles in suburbia tune
in to lifetime original movie hidden
fences I think you just stole the show
dan you just saw the show points to that
Betsy I have not seen hidden fences but
I know all you have to say is that it's
very important it's very important yeah